[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
size comparison of all dragons seen in
Game of Thrones and House of the Dragon
series including their writers and also
episodes where they were first seen
baby Vermax first seen in the fifth
episode of House of the Dragon he was
bonded with Prince jakaris valerion
iraqs this small juvenile dragon is
written by Prince lucaris valerion and
was first seen in the 10th episode of
House of the Dragon
Vermax seen again in episode 10 of House
of the dragon vermex by then had grown
and was a sub-addled dragon
sun fire Sunfire was first seen in
episode 6 of House of the Dragon among
other several dragons in drift mob and
he is written by aegon Targaryen
see smoke sea smoke is written by
Leonard valerion and was a white dragon
first seen in episode 3 and looked very
similar to Danny's dragons
Cyrax Cyrus was born into Queen renera
Targaryen and she was first seen in
episode 1 as a smaller type of dragon
and then grew a little bit bigger by the
last episode
dream fire another one that looked very
similar to Danny's dragons she was seen
once in episode 5 and again in episode 6
as she is Princess Helena targaryen's
dragon
Regal he is one of dany's dragons from
Game of Thrones here we're gonna see the
biggest size that he was in in the last
episode he was written by Jon Snow
viserion another one of Danny's dragons
and was yellowish in color he was later
killed by the night King in the seventh
season
Undead viserion or white viserion the
other dragon that was once viserion is
now a white and blue dragon white and
blue in color and was written by the
night King
drogon drug on by season 7 and season 8
of Game of Thrones is now a fully grown
dragon and is fully under the command of
Daenerys he is the biggest of that
series
garaxi's also known as the blood worm he
was first seen in episode 1 of House of
the dragon and was Bonnet to Prince
Daemon Targaryen
melees also known as the Red Queen she
is bonded to princess rain is Targaryen
and was first seen in episode 5 of House
of the Dragon
vomitar seen slightly in the last
episode of House of the Dragon Verma
Thor is yet to be claimed in the series
vegar seen as the biggest living Dragon
yet in the series of House of the Dragon
Vega is now currently bonded with Eamonn
Targaryen
valerion dead in the series but Valerian
is still seen as a skull in the red keep
and was last bonded with King viserys
Targaryen
the cannibal a wild dragon that hasn't
been seen yet in the show but is a fan
favorite so we have decided to include
him here he is rumored to be as big or
even bigger than valerion
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam